all right welcome to the live stream
I'll give it a couple minutes for people
to get connected and all of that stuff
I'll minimize this other monitor for a
bit just so it doesn't reflect in the
background we are going to be live
fact-checking to the extent that it can
be done live it'll sort of depend on the
number of lies
that are told per minute or per second
as may be is better said with Donald
Trump the presidential address that will
be taking place at 9:00 p.m. Eastern at
the top of the hour welcome to people
joining us in Europe where it is late in
the UK and even later in May excuse me
mainland Europe and much much later in
Eastern Europe welcome to everybody who
is joining us in the United States as
well we are thank you oh that that's
actually going to be annoying I don't
think we're gonna be able to deal with
that I seem to have an alert set up
every time someone subscribes on YouTube
and because of the yep there it is again
because of the massive number of
subscribers that we constantly get on
YouTube that's gonna get extraordinarily
annoying so let me see how I can turn
that off we want we do not want
subscriber alerts okay let me turn that
off and see I guess I have to save
settings let's that that I apologize for
that that's going to be extraordinarily
and annoying if it keeps going so let me
turn it off in one spot and subscribers
is already off in another spot so why is
that continuing to come up subscribers
oh it we added itself how is that
possible I refreshed and subscriber
alerts are back on I may have to
turn that off hmm man I wish I had
planned this already uh properly that
we've never had this issue before and it
keeps turning itself on yeah so I might
have to delete that entire thing or it's
going to keep going off this entire time
fortunately because we have so many
people who are subscribing all the time
so that I think is man and I can't just
mute that no boy this is a problem maybe
if I delete let's see I think I've taken
care of it took care of it in one shot
eventually we will be going over to the
Trump thing over here and we also need
to get rid of it here let's see if we
can do that getting rid of that there
and getting rid of that okay and then if
we take this full screen okay I don't
think it's going to be a problem there
so we've got this shot ready to go for
when this whole thing gets going and
then we can come back to me okay I'll
have to figure out those alerts at some
other time but I apologize for that okay
so we will be taking super chats we will
be doing all sorts of different stuff
let me first sort of frame what we've
got going on today
number one normally these types of
presidential addresses are reserved for
non overtly political presidential
announcement so an example I gave on the
program earlier today is when george w
bush announced that the US was at war
with iraq of course the motivations for
that war were extraordinarily political
but letting the nation know that we were
at war would be a legitimate reason to
do a presidential address when President
Obama announced that Osama bin Laden had
been killed of course there were all
sorts of political repercussions but
announcing that that had taken place was
not in and of itself an overtly
political act Donald Trump tonight will
be using the presidential address for an
overtly political speech and my initial
sort of concern was that by doing this
tonight I was participating in the
problem
that is unchecked repetition of Trump
propaganda but I talked to a bunch of
people after today's show who emailed me
and said know if you're going to fact
check it you should do it because if you
don't do this
CNN is gonna run it anyway Fox News will
run it anyway you're you're not
improving the situation by doing nothing
and if you do live fact check and
sometimes on YouTube being first is
important in terms of getting a video up
we will as soon as we're done have an
archive uploaded video of the speech
with the fact-checking if people see
that when they search instead of the CNN
stream or the fox news stream or
whatever we're better off so that's why
I decided to do this now there's sort of
three layers of analysis aside from the
content of tonight's address that are
important to think about and we'll be
thinking about these as this eight
minute address is going on number one
what is the reality of whether what is
taking place at the border actually
warrants this type of presidential
address I've already addressed that and
I think the answer is no we have record
low number of crossings across the
border undocumented which has been on a
decline since before Trump was president
we have a net outflow of undocumented
immigrants to Mexico rather than a net
inflow from Mexico undocumented
immigrants commit crime at a lower rate
than american-born citizens they are
almost single-handedly responsible for
keeping a number of industries up and
running in the United States so there's
simply no crisis so that would be one
reason not to even do this at all next
even if you can prove that there is a
crisis which I don't believe there is
and I don't think there's any data that
would back that up you then need to
justify the border wall as the solution
and you need to justify it as a solution
with a price tag that makes sense it's
crazy that I'm even thinking of this
based on my politics and the politics of
many in our audience but there's this
viral clip on YouTube you can find of
economist Milton Friedman who's
politics and economic theories I don't
generally agree with kind of having a
back and forth with a young audience
member about a car a hypothetical car or
maybe it was a real car that had a
defect which led to some people being
injured or even killed and Milton
Friedman points out it's bad for cars to
kill people but at a certain point if
you go far enough you start getting to a
point that's crazy which is let's
imagine that it costs the car
manufacturer a million dollars to fix
each car and there was a point Oh 1%
chance of that car killing someone would
it still make sense for the government
to mandate a recall for example and of
course these these are hypotheticals
they're thought experiments but at a
certain point we would say no that
wouldn't make sense with the wall you
have 1/3 of undocumented immigrants
coming over via the us-mexico border 2/3
flying in and overstaying visas are
coming in via other ways if you say well
it would be great to stop that 33% fare
at a certain point though you would say
at what cost would that make sense would
it make sense if the wall costs 10,000
per deterred illegal crossing or a
hundred thousand or a million dollars or
what so even if you can prove that we
have an immigration crisis which we
don't even if you can prove that the
wall is the solution which I don't
believe you can given the relatively
small portion of undocumented immigrants
that are crossing that border and the
the relatively high cost and lack of
certainty that it will actually prevent
those crossings at a certain point you
have to say well what is the cost we are
incurring in order to put in place this
mediocre sort of non solution and at
that point I think that there is
absolutely no defense of this border
wall policy period full stop that's my
position and so that's sort of the
framework through which I will be
listening to this speech does Donald
Trump have any compelling data that
contradicts the overwhelming consensus
that
is not an acute crisis we're dealing
with right now and does he present any
new case for why the wall is the
solution and why the cost of that wall
is one that should be borne by the
American people because remember we were
told Mexico was going to pay for it
Mexico was never going to pay for it I
don't know anyone who is thinking
rationally that believed that a lot of
people not thinking who believe that
what happened to that so now you have to
make the case that it's the American
people that should pay for it so that's
the framework let's catch up on just a
few things so everybody knows what's
going on is we have about nine minutes
or so until this thing gets going if
this is your first live stream it's
great that because we own literally and
figuratively the means of production of
the David Pakman show we have access to
the studio 24/7 we can do a daily
broadcast show for 200 radio and TV
stations and then we can also do live
coverage so if this is your first stream
this is actually live you can ask
questions and send comments using super
chat which is the dollar sign at the
bottom of the chat window new members
and there's a few that have come in and
I will I will address them momentarily
new members and patrons who sign up
during the stream will get shoutouts
from me please don't troll the live chat
you can also use that join button to
become a youtube sponsor which is very
very cool and I will mention we have two
coupon codes available right now for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership if you like what we're doing
if you think it's important and useful
to have alternatives to corporate media
just airing the Trump speech the
propaganda speech if you think it's
valuable to have independent progressive
analysis I would encourage you to become
a member and if we get 10 new members
between now and the end of Trump's
propaganda address I'll open the phone
lines afterwards and we can hear what
people think about it and we'll take
questions if you want the phone lines
opened just 10 members there's two
coupon codes available if you want to
get a $60 membership for 20 bucks use
the coupon code 2019 ok it only works to
drop the $60 membership to $20.19 if you
just want to save 40% off of any
membership on our website use the coupon
code this is 20 20 this is 20 20 works
on any membership so if you want a
monthly membership for 3 bucks a month
you can use this as 20 20 as the coupon
code and we're not talking about a big
number if we just get 10 new subscribers
during the stream and as it turns out we
already have to Kali lindholm and Robin
Orban Griggs who have just signed up so
if we get 8 more new members during the
speech analysis and fact-checking
I'll open the phone calls after and the
more new members the longer I will keep
the the phone calls open so I hope that
we get audio properly coming through the
various streams that I have I have an
NBC stream ready to go and I also have
the white house stream ready to go and
sometimes I don't know why or how it
happens when we switch to these
sometimes during the stream we don't get
audio so that's why I have a backup
otherwise if all else fails I will just
have to listen in a second earpiece to
what Trump is saying and just relay it
to you which will make it really
difficult to fact-check and be relaying
to you what's going on so let's hope
that that that doesn't happen ok
as we wait let me deal with some of the
super chats that we've gotten so far and
I will leave this up on my main monitor
and rule in court sent a $2.00 super
chat saying thanks for doing this David
my pleasure this is why there's going to
be much more of the stuff in 2019 and
now that we have the new studio set up
now that we have a lot of other things
in place if there is demand for this if
people continue to support the streams I
will do them and we will cover all sorts
of events no one sent a one dollar super
chat no question or comment thank you
very much King Kozma has become a
youtube member and Greg Lukas has become
a YouTube member thanks to thanks to all
of you really appreciate that we so
here's the the question I have for you
when this thing gets going
should I sort of in a stream of
consciousness way try to fact-check what
trump says or because it's only an
eight-minute address
we are told although between the
sniffing and the reading problems it
could become fifteen should I just take
notes I have my laptop here ready to
take notes and then afterwards sort of
summarize maybe it doesn't make sense to
interrupt the speech every what might be
15 seconds if there are that many lies a
couple people saying
stream-of-consciousness
wait until he's done do it in the moment
do it after do it live summarize later
take the notes do it later do it after
after after most people seem to be
saying note so I think what I'll do is I
will take notes during this thing and
then afterwards if something really
absurd happens I'll point it out in in
real time but otherwise we'll mostly
talk about it after one dead chicken
cent to $5 super chat you're in for a
busy night hope Pat can keep up no one
sends a $2.00 super jet hi love your
content thank you Brian chambers with a
$10 super chat thank you Alonzo Cal Poly
Pomona with a dollar one cent super chet
AC 0 5 10 $10 super chat I appreciate
you and your channel a Harvey will you
get demonetised for streaming NBC News
maybe but you know if I don't care if
this video gets D monetized because
we've got super chats coming in
hopefully we'll get memberships coming
in which will cause me to open up the
phone lines after the event so that's
not a big deal awesome gaming $5.00
super chet thanks for doing this do you
think he will declare a national
emergency you know if you had asked me
four hours ago I would have said Trump
is declaring a national emergency
tonight now I'm not so sure and I think
that just devastating russia-related
news that is broken in the last several
hours showing actual coordination
between Paul Manafort and Russia during
the campaign related to the campaign now
I just I just don't know that Trump's
going to do that this might be a pretext
to declare a national emergency at some
future point clayton h new youtube
member Thank You Isaac Mendez thanks for
doing this thank you for being here
Isaac goat versus fish the goat fish
beware the fence beware the fence sitter
all right
you fifty two new YouTube member thank
you very much
and I also want to thank a boy we might
almost already be at the point where I
will take phone calls after the speech I
said if we get ten new members I will do
it
Matthew Upchurch has signed up Paul
Schultz or schultzy has signed up Celso
gomez has become a member on our website
Jeff fili and Ryan fuller all have
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership thank you thank you guys I
really do appreciate it and if we get
just a few more members I will open up
the phone lines after the Trump speech
I mean I'm struggling for what to even
call it and my fact-checking of it so
thanks very very much we are told it
will only go eight minutes which is
great I don't know that we can tolerate
too much more of that and I am hoping to
have audio I have the NBC stream pulled
up and I also have the White House
stream let's see what they've got going
here 40,000 people watching the White
House stream 35,000 people watching the
NBC stream I'd rather just take the
White House stream I tend to do that I
just have the NBC one here as a backup
it seems not to be live let me go back
to live okay there we go
is this one live yeah it is alright live
stream starting soon we we will get to
that a couple more Super chats art
Flores with a nine dollar $0.99 superjet
to quote jay-z driving Benzes with no
benefits not bad huh for some immigrants
build your fences we dig in tunnels
can't you see we get money up under you
lol PS David how's your day good day
good day busy day keV Zeeman longtime
fan I know this is a more serious kind
of channel but y'all should run a sniff
count I wish we had the resources for
that I really do a couple of new members
including um man things was happening
very quickly crowbar an awesome gaming
and Mike and Adele COO have signed up as
YouTube members Scott Taylor Davis says
I wonder how much will be prepared
speech and how much will be Trump
rambling I think he's probably been told
to stick to the script but you never
know when he'll do some of those
kind of like inline interjections let's
see
Irving de la Riva $2 super chat Bryan
Chambers is a new member
our Monde Tessier says what is the
square root of 9 I believe it's 3 right
3 times 3 is 9
David Gonzales big fan can't wait to
hear your commentary thank you
t yml thank you for the hard work you
and your team are doing retro ambassador
says you're doing great work as a
current member can I use the coupon code
to renew for another year you can but
you're sort of forgoing whatever balance
you've already paid for so on your
membership so you should only do it if
it's if depending on when your
membership renews all right it looks
like I'm hearing something it looks like
maybe things are supposed to be starting
it is 9:00 p.m. Eastern 6 p.m. Pacific
not seeing anything the stream is still
live maybe Trump is uh depending on who
you believe having a last little upper
before getting going presidential
address let's see if we can hear Lester
Holt the nation of the continuing in
casts over funding for his long promise
board ok so we'll just keep this low for
now I don't want to lose audio we will
open the phone lines after the event if
we get a bunch of new people signing up
at david pakman.com slash membership to
coupon codes available coupon code 2019
drops a $60 membership to $20.19 coupon
code this is 20 20 saves you 40% off of
the membership of your choice Kenneth
Guthrie is a new member John Perry is a
new member
Demetrios apostle I believe it is a new
member you and Ryan fuller I think I
already mentioned so keep those coming
it's looking good for taking calls see
what Lester Holt is talking about here
ending the wall without legislation that
would certainly almost speak challenge
certainly be challenged in court
Democratic leaders Nancy Pelosi and
Chuck Schumer will be responding to the
president tonight we will be carrying
that live as well yeah I should have
mentioned that so Pelosi and Schumer we
talked about this on today's bonus show
which you would know about if you were
already a member or patron Pelosi and
Schumer will be reacting
tonight they about oh wait here we go
let's see what I'm speaking to you
because there is a growing humanitarian
and security crisis and our southern
border every day Customs and Border
Patrol agents encounter thousands of
illegal immigrants trying to enter our
country we are at my place to hold them
and we have no way to promptly return
them back home to their country America
proudly welcomes millions of lawful
immigrants who would rich our society
and contribute to our nation but all
Americans are hurt by uncontrolled
illegal migration it strains public
resources and drives down jobs and wages
among those hardest hit are African
Americans and Hispanic Americans our
southern border is a pipeline for vast
quantities of illegal drugs including
meth heroin cocaine and fentanyl every
week 300 of our barely keep up are
killed by heroin alone 90% of which
floods across from our southern border
more Americans will die from drugs this
year than were killed in the entire
Vietnam War in the last two years ice
officers made 266 thousand arrests of
aliens with criminal records including
those charged or convicted of 100,000
assaults thirty thousand sex crimes this
is going to be tougher than a thousand
violent killings over the years
thousands of Americans have been
brutally killed by those who illegally
entered our country and thousands more
lives will be lost
if we don't act right now this is a
humanitarian crisis a crisis of the
heart and a crisis of the soul
last month 20,000 migrant children were
illegally brought into the United States
a dramatic increase these children are
used as human pawns this astonishes
coyotes and
ruthless gangs one in three women are
sexually assaulted on the dangerous trek
up through Mexico women our children are
the biggest victims by far of our broken
system this is the tragic reality of
illegal immigration on our southern
border this is the cycle of human
suffering that I am determined to end my
administration has presented Congress
with a detailed proposal to secure the
border and stop the criminal gangs drug
smugglers and human traffickers it's a
tremendous problem I have 10 lies and
one distortion so [ __ ] by law
enforcement professionals and border
agents at the Department of Homeland
Security these are the resources they
have requested to properly perform their
mission and keep America safe in fact
safer than ever before the proposal from
Homeland Security includes cutting-edge
technology for detecting drugs weapons
illegal contraband and many other things
we have requested more agents
immigration is not an emergency folks
this is simply not an emergency surprise
an unlawful migration fueled by our very
strong economy our plan also contains an
urgent request for humanitarian
assistance and medical support
furthermore we have asked Congress to
close border security loopholes so that
illegal immigrant children can be safely
and humanely returned back home finally
as part of an overall approach to border
security law enforcement professionals
have requested 5.7 billion dollars for a
physical barrier at the request of
Democrats it will be a steel barrier
rather than a concrete wall this barrier
is absolutely critical to border
security it's also what our
professionals at the border want indeed
this is just common sense the border
wall would very quickly pay for itself
the cost of illegal drugs exceeds 500
billion dollars a year vastly more than
the 5.7 billion dollars we have
requested from Congress the wall will
also be paid for indirectly by the great
new trade deal we have made with Mexico
Senator Chuck Schumer who you will be
hearing from later tonight has
repeatedly supported a physical barrier
in the past along with many other
Democrats they change their mind
only after I was elected president
Democrats in Congress have refused to
acknowledge the crisis and they have
refused to provide our brave border
agents with the tools they desperately
need to protect our families and our
nation the federal government remains
shut down for one reason and one reason
only because Democrats will not fund
border security my administration is
doing everything that that's maybe the
biggest lie help those impacted by the
situation but the only solution is for
Democrats to pass a spending bill that
defends our borders and reopens the
government this situation could be
solved in a 45-minute meeting I have
invited congressional leadership to the
White House tomorrow to get this done
hopefully that was weak that was my lie
detector breaking I apologize in order
to support national security some have
suggested a barrier is immoral then why
do wealthy politicians build walls
fences and gates around their homes they
don't build walls because they hate the
people on the outside but because they
love the people on the inside the only
thing that is immoral is the politician
to do nothing and continue to allow more
innocent people to be so horribly
victimized America's heart broke the day
after Christmas when a young police
officer in California was savagely
murdered in cold blood by an illegal
alien
it just came across the border the life
of an American Hero was stolen by
someone who had no right to be in our
country
day after day precious lives are cut
short by those who have violated our
borders in California lot of sin affair
force Madison is raped murdered I'm
beaten to death with a hammer by an
illegal alien with a long criminal
history in Georgia an illegal alien was
recently charged with murder for killing
beheading and dismembering his neighbor
in Maryland ms-13 gang members who
arrived in the United States as
unaccompanied minors were arrested and
charged last year after viciously
stabbing and beating a 16 year old girl
over the last several years I've met
with dozens of families whose loved ones
were stolen by illegal immigration I've
held the hands of the weeping mothers
and embraced the grief-stricken father's
so sad so terrible I will never forget
the pain in their eyes that tremble in
their voices and the sand
note that the lies have stopped and now
it's just anecdotes that don't justify
us particular policy before Congress
does its job for those who refuse to
compromise in the name of border
security
I would ask imagine if it was your child
your husband or your wife whose life was
so cruelly shattered
and totally broken to every member of
Congress pass a bill that ends this
crisis to every citizen call Congress
and tell them to finally after all of
these decades secure our border this is
a choice between right and wrong justice
and injustice this is about whether we
fulfill our sacred duty through the
American citizens we serve not really
now when I took the oath of office I
swore to protect our country and that is
what I will always do so help me God
thank you Rick and good night oh my
goodness okay so a little longer than
eight minutes but roughly as as as
promised where to start my lie detector
actually broke and I had to bring in a
hand-cranked one because that was just
endlessly stunning so there were kind of
two parts of the speech I don't know if
you noticed and though I will open up
the phone lines in a bit as new members
continue to come in using the coupon
codes thanks for joining us by the way
this is live coverage and live
fact-checking of what Donald Trump is
claiming as an immigration crisis
justifying the building of a physical
border wall there were sort of two parts
to this there was the first part which
was just lies then there was part two
which was sort of appealing to emotion
and a bunch of other logical fallacies
and referring to some tragic crimes that
have been committed but which still
don't justify the particular policy that
Trump is talking about it's just
fear-mongering so number one after
watching this it never should have
happened this was a purely political
lobbying speech this is not what the
commandeering of national television for
presidential announcements is supposed
to be used for number one Donald Trump
opened by saying there is a crisis
saying there's a crisis doesn't make it
so Trump said that there are that there
are no he said that we have no way I
can't even find it I mean there's just
so many lies he said that we have no way
to quickly return people to where they
came from that's not true sort of
subjective you can decide what it means
for something to be quick but we do have
something called due process in this
country the only way to speed it up is
one reopen the government so that the
immigration hearings can continue
they're shut down because the government
shut down or to eliminate due process
which we are not going to do mostly we
are not being hurt by undocumented
immigrants Donald Trump had some
anecdotes of undocumented immigrants
that committed violent crimes here of
course most violent crimes
overwhelmingly and at a higher rate
committed by american-born citizens it
is not really straining resources
because there are resources that go to
dealing with undocumented immigration
but remember undocumented immigrants are
single-handedly holding up multiple
industries including agriculture where
we get our food you know if you live in
Massachusetts in the winter and you're
having oranges and bok choy and whatever
else who do you think is working in
agriculture to a greater degree than the
percentage of the population that they
represent
restaurant industry etc they're paying
into social programs from which they
will never get money out because they
are undocumented so it's not straining
resources we have widely debunked this
we've done a big deep dive on this issue
he talks about how this is driving down
wages how undocumented immigrants coming
to the u.s. is driving down wages
corporations that hire undocumented
immigrants want that okay and this is
the big con Donald Trump and people of
his ilk when it comes to this issue have
successfully bamboozled many people in
the United States into being mad about
low wages at people coming to the u.s.
to work right the opposite of laziness
abandoning your country and sometimes
your family risking arrest or death
to come and work to improve your
family's life it is the corporation's
who continue to hire them and are not
punished by the choice of this and every
administration and yet people aren't mad
at the corporation's they're mad at the
immigrants who mostly are coming here to
work absolutely disgusting Americans are
dying from drugs but that doesn't lead
to saying we need a border wall most of
what's coming over is marijuana
people aren't dying from marijuana there
is heroin coming over there is cocaine
coming over but of course that problem
is not going to go away if you put up a
wall Trump saying it's a humanitarian
crisis it doesn't make it one Trump says
that there are thousands of people being
killed every year by undocumented
immigrants I've not seen that data that
seems to me like a drastic exaggeration
I simply don't have the numbers in front
of me but I have not seen that data
Trump pointing out that women and
children are always the big are the
biggest victims women and children are
almost always the biggest victims that
doesn't justify any particular policy
including the one that Donald Trump is
advocating for Donald Trump is asking
for a lot of things in addition to the
wall all of those other things Democrats
have said they're willing to give him in
exchange for reopening government but
not the wall so when Donald Trump's talk
talks about border security and
technology and all of this other stuff
Democrats have been willing to provide
that it's Mitch McConnell and Donald
Trump who have decided they're not going
to consider it if it comes from
Democrats but that's a non-sequitur
Democrats have already said they'll give
them that stuff we've just got to get
government reopened saying that the wall
is a critical piece of border security
doesn't make it so you've got to
demonstrate that it is untrue that
everybody wanted a wall until Donald
Trump was president and said that he
wants to build a wall there have been
many people on the left and right who
have said we would be open to in
exchange for a bunch of other stuff
funding some border fence miles on the
southern border in key areas that's
different than saying I am going to
throw a tantrum unless you fund the
entire walls
starting with 5 billion those are two
different things don't be tricked into
thinking that those are the same thing
Donald Trump is saying that people are
not even acknowledging the crisis right
because it's not a crisis so that's a
criticism without actually having any
substance government is not shut down
because of Democrats maybe the biggest
lie of the night was Donald Trump saying
government is shut down because of
Democrats it's not I think most people
watching know this Donald Trump said in
the Oval Office to Chuck Schumer and
Nancy Pelosi that he would proudly shut
it down and he did shut it down period
okay so that's that it's it's maybe the
biggest lie and then Donald Trump starts
listing these individual crimes that
have taken place committed by
undocumented immigrants again it their
all tragic but it doesn't justify 25
billion or 30 billion or 35 billion
whatever it's ultimately going to cost
for a border wall it also doesn't prove
that the border wall would have
prevented all of those crimes and then
he did something interesting which is he
said imagine if it was your husband or
wife or daughter who was killed Mike
Dukakis when he ran for president I
believe it was he was asked about his
position on the death penalty governor
Dukakis what if it was your daughter who
was raped wouldn't you though or your
wife wouldn't you then want the death
penalty and I don't remember what he
said but it wasn't the right answer and
whenever someone says that and tries to
get an emotional reaction the right
answer is always you can draw up a
scenario where I would want revenge
because I'm personally affected that
doesn't mean that we should make policy
based on that and that is it's an it's
an appeal to emotion that works which is
listen you might not want the wall but
what if your sister was killed after
being raped by an undocumented immigrant
wouldn't you want it then well I might
but the fact that I would be acting out
of out of emotion and devastation
wouldn't make it the right policy it's
it's literally a logical fallacy out of
the the list of logical fallacies so
amazing the number of lies and
distortions and non sequiturs that were
stuffed into this short speech truly
amazing and we will
dig into it more tomorrow on the program
for sure I think I'm gonna open the
phone lines briefly the number is 6 1 7
8 3 0 47 50 we can hear what people are
thinking about this you are able to
start calling in now if you would like I
want to thank a bunch of other new
members including Nick Leon see it's
just been a stream of new members David
watts
Ryan Pipkin Sarah bond mayor Jennifer
slappy John Harbor and a bunch of other
people that I named before thanks to
everybody keeps signing up at david
pakman.com slash membership really
really appreciate it every single one of
you that is supporting the work we do
says you care about what we do if you
value what we're doing please support it
ok if you're new to this program if
you've never seen this before you don't
know yet whether you value what we do or
not that's fine you don't have the money
if you can't afford to support us
financially that's fine I'm doing this
program for everybody regardless of
whether you can pay but we are funded by
viewers and listeners mostly through
something called membership ww join
pakman.com - coupon codes are available
tonight coupon code number 1 is this is
20/20 this is 2 0 2 0 that'll save you
40% off of the membership of your choice
the other coupon code available is 2019
two zero one nine this is going away
tomorrow that'll drop a $60 membership
to $20.19 you're all set for the year
and you can keep that price for as long
as you want so keep signing up and I'll
keep thanking members who sign up let's
go to the phones now 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 I
see a 7 7 4 area code which is usually
here in Massachusetts let's go there
first
7 7 4 what's going on hi David I'm
calling in from Boston Massachusetts
your area
name is Jeremy and I'm Jeremy where I'm
speaking right we don't have you two
we're not on speaker or a Bluetooth yeah
no my theater
go ahead just a little bit of an eye
tracker I know he's but go ahead sorry
Michael it had to do with the 2020
Democratic primaries um to what extent
do you think that medicare-for-all is
going to become sort of a litmus test
for progressives and even for moderate
Democrats and do you see most the field
embracing it so here's how it will mow
let most likely go down it will become a
litmus test but only in terms of a soft
commitment okay so the way that the
Democrats that are that aren't really in
favor of it or maybe are in favor of it
personally but don't want to jeopardize
their relationships with beforebut
insurance companies and if you can turn
down whatever's on in the background or
I can always get sounds like it's
getting very very crazy there here's
what Democrats will do they'll just say
I would love to think of Medicare for
all or single-payer as the end goal I
think it's a great thing to aspire to
but but but but but but so that's why in
the short term what I want to do is
increase access tweak Obamacare etc etc
etc that's the way that they'll pass the
litmus test if it becomes one without
really endangering their relationship
with for-profit insurance companies
let's go to the four eight zero area
code I think four eight zero is that's
Arizona isn't it I gave it this is miles
how my first of all I want to say you
did a really good analysis of Alexander
Cassio Cortez is seventy percent tax
something that I agree with but
unfortunately not a lot of people in my
family or friends agree with which is
unfortunate but you did a very good job
with that
and my question would be I guess sort of
book do you believe that that you
believe that what Trump said just a few
moments ago was basically a state of
emergency like that's what some people
were saying no no no so declaring I mean
so okay colloquially yes he was making
it seem as though this is an emergency
right that that's the whole premise but
he didn't declare a state of emergency
that would be some that's a formal
declaration that a president can make
and there was some suspicion that that's
what he might be doing
tonight there's some suspicious that he
would have had it not been for the just
devastating news related to the Trump
Russia investigation that broke a couple
hours ago yeah but he did not declare a
state of emergency tonight what happened
you said uh Trump knew Russia news
happened a couple hours ago what
happened yeah so there have been do do
this is just unbelievable we'll have
full coverage of this tomorrow because
of Paul man affords lawyers we're just
not knowing what on earth they're doing
they and hey I'm gonna let you go I
don't know everybody seems to be having
a party in the background Paul man
affords lawyers made it possible to look
at some unredacted documents which point
to testimony conceding by Paul Manafort
that he was coordinating with Russia
specifically related to the Trump
campaign as the campaign was going on
and as he was campaign chairman which is
the first a court document of its kind
by someone saying yes I did it right
it's no longer accusations from others
so we'll have full coverage of that
tomorrow let's go next to our caller
from the eight six four area code by the
way the number to call in is six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
if you're wondering that is the number
caller from eight six four go ahead hi
this is Ryan Zimmerman from Greenville
South Carolina um first of all thank you
for the show it's a fantastic show on
YouTube I think it's good every day my
question is concerning the current rise
in right wing and and self-proclaimed
classical liberal youtubers out there
and I was wondering what your opinion is
of them in the general sense and also if
you think they are a prominent figure in
the and helping people go into the polls
and voting for allegedly process the
wrong reasons the second part I think
the answer is no I've not seen any
evidence at least that the Internet
classical liberal movement is motivating
people to vote that wouldn't otherwise
because listen classical liberalism is
sort of niche in in the sense of being a
kind of discreet and defined movement so
no I don't really think that it's
getting people to the polls who wouldn't
otherwise go I think it's a lot of
people who are already politically
engaged although not all
I don't want to I don't want to totally
cast a wide net there you know my view
there's sort of two different questions
in question one one is what do I think
of the classical liberalism YouTube
stuff I think there's a lot of nonsense
floating around a lot of confusion a lot
of missed statements of what classical
liberalism even really is there's a lot
of just saying I'm a classical liberal
but without actually being one as far as
you know it as a movement that is out
there to become a promotional tool I
think it's been pretty successful
anytime that you can kind of create a
new movement but put a name on it
you often will do really well in getting
people to say I've now found my tribe or
my group or my niche so to speak so
there's a lot of people making good
money with this classical liberalism
meme whether or not they even understand
it oh cool also briefly do you have any
suggestions on like people from the
other side of YouTube that you was like
to the interested in or promoting
[Music]
whatsoever in promoting any right-wing
youtubers tonight but appreciate the
opportunity for the call okay let's go
next to our caller from the 95 to area
code and 9/5 who's this 9 5 - hey David
this is Jackson Minnesota okay give me
one second and then we'll I'll get to
your question I do want to thank Paul
Greenberg Walter steward Jessica Sanchez
Vaughn Coleman or cool man
Luke Gwyn Catalan Heyman she Shane fair
and Garrett Morris
for signing up for memberships on our
website thanks to all of you okay
9:52 let's get right into it sure so I
had a policy this question like this so
what is your ideal I guess what would a
living wage system look like if you
could have it your way
would you rather have it tied to the
state level or the county or how would
you want to see it implemented and you
have any evidence that pointed you in
that direction I've read
studies that differ in terms of what so
ok the question is premise Thanh the
idea that some kind of federal living
wage would be very difficult because
cost of living varies so drastically
from the bronies of I don't know what
the cheapest state is I don't put
there's parts of Alaska that are just so
cheap to live to New York City and Los
Angeles and Boston and DC so federally
you're not going to be able to set one
living wage number that makes sense
state-level makes a little more sense
but even within states
you see drastic differences Boston
versus Peru Massachusetts which is
actually a place or Florida
Massachusetts which are really really
cheap places to live the problem of
continuing to go narrower and saying
let's do a county level for example is
that it's very easy to work in one
County and live in another and the the
cost of living can be very different
from one County to the next and you also
need to determine is it based on where
you work or where you live what about
people who work from home what about
people who travel for work where do we
assign them so I I've not yet taken a
firm position on how we would index it
but I'm completely on board with you
that it needs to be more nuanced than
federal and probably even more nuanced
than even state level okay and I have a
really quick follow-up question yeah so
um so what evidence we seen just in
general that supports the ideal about
raising some level of the minimum wage
is economically a good idea there any
specific I mean listen there there's
countless studies that have looked in
different areas at what the impacts
would be I don't have any of them
prepared in front of me now to say but I
think that the general idea would be
that obviously picking some cartoonishly
high number to say this is the minimum
wage wouldn't work
you know $200 an hour or whatever but
that's typically a common strawman from
the right that's not what we would call
an equilibrium wage in any way I think
that or if you believe in demand side
stimulus you would understand that
modest increases
either something back dating to the late
60s based on inflation based on cost of
living that would provide significant
demand-side stimulus but only would have
a very small impact on prices cool all
right I appreciate the thoughtful
questions thank you okay let's put we're
next going to our caller from the 703
area code which if I recall correctly is
Virginia but before we do that let me
say thanks to Jay a Calton who is a new
member I will thank Garrett Morris for
the order of david pakman show coffee
please order david pakman show coffee or
we might get rid of it okay david
pakman.com slash gear and okay that's
that's it for now so 7:03 what's going
on hi I'm 15 years old one from Virginia
oh great um yeah we're wondering um
should we prioritize reducing the debt
or should we promote should we focus on
promoting economic growth what why so
let me ask why are you why is it
either/or
because that's the topic for something I
have to do for school okay here's how so
I'm not going to do your homework for
you but I would take issue with the
premise of the question the question
implies that and that economic growth
and reducing the debt are opposed I've
not seen any evidence to suggest that so
I would take issue with the question and
I would fight the premise if I were you
okay all right man record the
conversation explaining that to your
teacher let's go to the 202 area code
call her from 202 go ahead
hello David mi life you're live right
now okay great I just have a question if
there was a Democrat in 2020 like could
they appeal that Trump voters who said
by saying look he's not done anything
that he said he was going to do I don't
see how he
do anything anything more that he
promised he was going to do let alone
the border wall do you think that he
they could appeal to Trump voters and
changed their minds or do you think
those people they're a Democrat it's
just not that's just not territory a
Democrat can't get into I think that it
is territory that a Democrat could get
into the question that I would ask and
this is what I've been talking about for
a long time on my show in terms of you
know you talk about convincing Trump
voters I don't think it's the time
efficient way to run a campaign and the
reason why is it's going to take you a
lot more effort to change the mind of a
trumpet than it is to simply get out the
vote from people who are already
sympathetic to your politics and I think
that this applies at the
get-out-the-vote level for activists but
I also think it applies from the point
of view of candidates so am I saying
that the Democratic nominee should
ignore trumpets and just write them off
of course not but we've seen that they
are sort of impervious to fact and
therefore I wouldn't focus on trying to
change the minds of existing Trump
supporters only half the country votes
you can win just on turnout and I would
focus on getting people to vote by
making them understand why not voting
last time was such a mistake got it and
another question do you think Trump in
order to declare emergency powers do you
think Trump could like you like it
deliberately start like a crisis or
something like start a war with another
country god forbid or something like
that as an excuse to gain emergency
powers and then build this wall would
you put that past him I would not put it
past him although I don't know about
straight up starting a war but I think
there are probably intermediate things
that that he could do and you know you
could make the case that what he did
tonight that that the address tonight
was potentially part of a pretext to do
exactly that thanks for the call I
really appreciate it great night all
right
the memberships keep rolling in I want
to say thanks to every Quinta
and Margo Northam Jason Anderson thank
you all for signing up I'll take a few
more calls let's do something else just
to just to mix it up let's do another
challenge tonight since we've got so
many people here we have 1585 patrons
right now if we get to 1,600 patrons
just 15 patrons
I will I've seen a bunch of requests for
this in the chat I will take a couple
challenges on leaches org from the
audience and get crushed in a couple of
chess games people from the audience
like crushing crushing me in chess I
will allow it if we just get 15 patrons
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
even if they're just for $1 a month but
we should do it somewhat soon because
it's it's a school night for me so I've
got to get to that okay let's go to the
909 area code caller from 909 who's this
what's going on so this is Darius from
Southern California I have a question
for you yeah
yeah well there's a couple ways that
this is a good question there's a couple
ways in which that would happen one is
and I know that a lot of the elites end
up paying taxes when they file rather
than getting refunds back because they
don't they don't overpay but in February
the filing window is going to open for
people's taxes and if people can't get
the refunds they're entitled to because
of the shutdown you will very quickly
see the elites as you call them start
telling Trump you got to cut the [ __ ]
also with the TSA with TSA working
without pay at a certain point that's
going to put airports at risk of closing
that will shut down industry and that
will also very quickly get things moving
I know that the the elite elites are
flying private not with TSA but a lot of
them are not a lot of them are flying on
commercial flights and I think that
those are two things that would pretty
quickly get people to say hey this has
got to end
uh well yeah I mean so they might but
it's ultimately up to making a deal with
Democrats right so I think that just if
a few Blue Dog Democrats are open to
building the wall I don't think that at
this point that gives them the votes in
the house to actually get the funding
Trump wants all right no appreciate you
calling it let's go to the 978 area code
caller from 978 go ahead what's going on
yes you are
you are live so I am 16 I are from a lot
of DeLarge there I wanted I wanted to
know that basically Trump is with Trump
has a pretty much stress during his
speech about the border security and
Border Patrol and such and I wanted to
know what whether there is a realistic
way to ensure security control but
without I don't know bill wasting
billions and trillions of dollars on a
wall yep so a couple things that a lot
of things that can be done one is in
terms of the physical border you're
going to do much better with some of the
technology solutions that have been
thrown out including drones and cameras
and a bunch of other stuff that's that's
the border wall specifically but the
best thing we could do is start
punishing all the companies that employ
undocumented immigrants because if
undocumented immigrants who remember
they're mostly coming here to work
they're not lazy they're coming here to
work if they can't get hired the impetus
to come to the United States is going to
be chopped down drastically so that is
one thing that would be a much better
investment of our time and resources and
if we work with the countries that the
undocumented immigrants are coming from
rather than the way we typically do
which is to worsen the circumstances in
those countries but to actually improve
circumstances you will also reduce the
number of people that are trying to come
to the United States and you will better
the world economy so those would be my
top three okay another another question
is more
here to you I know what do you what do
you ever consider vote voting for some
someone or a political candidate who is
identified as a Republican I know you're
mostly not a Republican but yes of
course
if I go to the polls and the person who
has the politics that most aligned with
me has an R next to their name I would
vote for them I'm not I'm an independent
I'm not registered with any party and I
would vote for whoever shares my views
most closely as long as the policy very
much a lot very much aligned with the
the problems are realistic toward you
then you would go for them absolutely
okay all right thank you so much
appreciate it thank you appreciate the
call let me say thanks to a few new
members I will say thank you to hip
pluriel and Joseph kick see thanks to
both of you
let's go to the 804 area code caller
from 804 go ahead you did yeah there you
are okay well um so I wanted to ask you
to what extent do you think fear plays a
role in realizing a president because
we've seen what that can do in terms of
like Bush he got reelected I think
mostly out of fear do you think that
could play a role in the 2020 election
because absolutely like chomp is
stroking the spears of flame the the the
you know what I'm trying to say it seems
like he's fear-mongering he's trying to
get people worked up do you think that
that would play a significant role I
think it could and this is why you know
whoever is ultimately the Democratic
candidate and corporate media are going
to need to be responsible and not allow
the fear-mongering
not allow concocted non actual crises to
take over the narrative and scare people
into that we can't change horses
midstream type of stuff you know I think
that the one thing working against Trump
on that narrative is he's not been
touting the
I've kept a safe stuff partially because
it would seem you know I would hope that
if he tries it that people would say
yeah what about all of the shootings
you've done nothing to actually deal
with the gun violence issue and people
aren't actually safe even if you can
kind of get around the terrorist attack
component but yes you're correctly
identifying that Trump is using fear
more and more you're correctly
identifying that it could play a big
role in the 2020 election and you know
whether it's literally an October
Surprise or something that just sort of
happens in the summer lead-up to the
2020 election we've got to be prepared
for it because they can have a very big
impact okay and I'm one more question
yeah um do you think that how Trump
keeps repeating and a lot of the
Republicans keep repeating this this lie
that Democrats are only voting against
the wall are they're they're holding the
government hostage for this wall because
Trump is the one proposing it and that
they were in favor of a wall before he
got in office how how long do you think
they'll be able to like parrot that lie
before people actually realize that that
it's just completely not sure and
there's nothing true about it probably
for a long time because people don't
really understand that just because a
Democrat when Obama was president was
open to giving Republicans a few miles
of border fence in exchange for stuff
they were proposing that's not the same
as saying they're in favor of a twenty
five thirty or thirty-five billion
dollar wall across the entire us-mexico
border they're two different things but
unfortunately the right is really good
at confusing people so they'll probably
be able to get away with that one for a
very long time thank you appreciate the
call thank you
okay we've got time for a few more calls
thanks to Jeff Cesar for signing up for
a membership at WWJ in Batman comm
caller from the five-10 area code what's
going on hello that is you hello that's
you oh hey hey David I really liked your
analysis thank you and I also want
- oh yeah I also want to ask how do you
think this issue is going to pick up in
the next couple of days and what do you
think people's reaction is going to be I
have no clue what the reactions going to
be because I'm so in this all the time
that I see a bold-faced liar
you know period that's it but maybe it
will end up being persuasive to people
there's a couple different ways it will
go one is it works and it gets Democrats
to give the guy some funding to is
literally nothing happens and he has to
come up with something else which might
be declaring a state of emergency and
commandeering the money for the wall or
some third option at this point I really
don't know I think I've got to kind of
sleep on it yeah and I also think you'll
be interesting to see how everything
will do in the next couple of days
agreed we will be covering it on the
show thank you appreciate your phone
call let's go next to the - six - area
code caller from - six - go ahead hello
hmm hi hey
so I'm I'm in Milwaukee monkey Wisconsin
um and I just wanted to point out that
this very interesting mm-hmm that 2/3 of
people coming in illegal immigration as
you pointed out come in overstaying
visas and with this book shut down the
TSA being adversely affected right
ironically people coming in to be
reduced because of I just I just find it
very ironic yes see I mean I understand
your point TSA does not you know TSA is
for people try if you come in from
another country on a plane you're going
through customs not TSA but I still
you're still making a valid point and
and even a better one I think would be
that there are deportations that aren't
happening because immigration courts are
delayed because of the shutdown so
there's actually more people staying
here who are undocumented because of the
shutdown which is obviously I mean you
know everything's backwards at this
point
it would be interesting if that was an
actual plan that he had but I highly
doubt that I I don't think he's capable
of that type of multi-dimensional
thinking appreciate the call thank you
so much let's take a couple more let's
go to the five zero one area code and I
want to thank Brian land who is our
newest david pakman show member go ahead
501 hey David on the show pleasure okay
so I'm 16 years old and do some history
class for going over the you know the
southern border and I was in Arkansas so
it's very per conservative and it just
probably a few questions I've had
because like all I can find is like you
know there's I'm sorry to interrupt you
I am having the hardest time
understanding what you're saying I heard
Arkansas and southern border but I I
apologize I'm not sure what you're
saying okay so being in Arkansas I hear
a bunch of stuff about the border yes
okay gotta have a couple questions good
okay so we had a watched video from mark
guys about about Democrat Chuck Schumer
he was talking about 2013 when under the
Obama administration he had to or they
found a twenty billion dollar Act to
help build offenses and so Halla being a
tween billion dollar deal how is that
different than Trump the only a
super-popular dollars yeah so we
actually we've we've already dealt with
that twice on the stream so I don't want
to bore the audience with it again but
you know that I've dealt with that twice
already and and that that's a wide lead
I won't we're talking to my bar we'll
check it out okay I appreciate the call
I don't want to do it a third time just
because it's gonna be on the stream
three times if I do let's do the nine
one zero area code caller from nine one
zero go ahead
all right there David hey all right so
what early what do you think do you
think the next president you know when
Trump ever does leave leave office is
going to have to have to deep deal with
on the international stage given that
Trump has seemed to really damage pretty
much the United States credibility and
relationships almost across the entire
world yep the next president is going to
have their work cut out for them they
will be working they will be fighting an
uphill battle to re-establish the
damaged relationships with our allies
now the one good thing is most of our
allies want to be on good terms with us
and I think that they would understand I
don't think they would hold against a
future president that Donald Trump was
such a [ __ ] and alienated them I think
because of the sort of bully pulpit that
the United States represents because of
being a country with the economic
importance that we are I think that even
though Trump is going to do a ton of
damage to our alliances I think most of
our allies with whom Trump is ruining
relationships will pretty quickly come
back around once Trump is gone but then
you've got the reputational aspect then
Donald Trump has made it so that the
United States is not a serious
participant in conversations about
climate change anymore you are seeing a
whole bunch of other areas in which it
just doesn't you don't need Trump in the
room you don't need the American
president in the room when it's Trump so
it'll be an uphill battle and it will
take years but I think it will be doable
okay thank you appreciate the call thank
you okay that's gonna do it for me took
a lot of calls we got dozens and dozens
of new members this video will be
archived I appreciate everybody who
joined me I will stream again and we
will have detailed analysis and
follow-up about what we saw tonight
on tomorrow's program and thanks to Mike
pond one last member who just signed up
thank you